[Musik]
manche sehen das ungewisse als potenzial
für einen youtube
andere sehen darin eher probleme die nur
darauf warten uns zu begegnen
[Musik]
es ist also eine berechtigte frage
warum brauchen wir wissen
doch lässt sich der bau einer mondbasis
eigentlich rechtfertigen wie sieht die
batterie der zukunft aus der wendelstein
7-x jedes bild eines schwarzen lochs
dass du je gesehen hast bist fett
künstliche intelligenz dringt in immer
mehr bereiche unseres lebens zeigt was
ist das teuerste objekt das sie von der
menschheit geschaffen wurde
heute und in den nächsten videos stelle
ich euch die schräge welt der quanten
vor
jedenfalls lässt mich die vorstellung
dass ich das unter umständen noch
miterleben kann
voller vorfreude in die zukunft blicke
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
auf doktor watson
[Musik]